he's won many races in his career but
this one was special for joe appear
his return to fitness after cancer
he was diagnosed with prostate cancer
last july but told he'd have to wait for
surgery
i mean that was a huge
blow for me and that was because of the
issues with the pandemic and the waiting
list by the time he had the operation in
september the cancer had already
progressed from stage two to stage three
i think that's the one of the most scary
is that you've got something inside you
that's growing that could potentially
could be fatal
so for me i just wanted it out
and it was very scary
and you can see that there's so many
people that have not gone forward
because of the pandemic
and there's so many people even if
they've gone forward they've not been
able to get seen because of the pandemic
as the country went into lockdown
millions of people missed out on vital
cancer screening
covered patient numbers surged and
referrals for suspected cancer fell
dramatically
but over the last year a record-breaking
2.7 million people have been referred
for cancer checks of those 315 000 have
started treatment for cancer but there
are still 30 000 people who haven't yet
started treatment due to the pandemic
the nhs says mobile clinics and
one-stop-shop testing sites are making
it easier to get a diagnosis
but gps say patients are still facing
delays the first step of things like
scans or blood tests or perhaps
biopsies or endoscopies that's the first
step and there is a waiting list there
and then the second step is if cancer is
confirmed then they need to see a
specialist
cancer team an oncology team and there's
also weightiness there as well so the
good news is patients are coming forward
the challenge for the nhs is to make
sure that we manage to meet that demand
a demand that will only be met by
recruiting more staff we really need to
make sure that as well as clearing the
current backlog that we've got the right
numbers of doctors nurses oncologists to
provide that care and support in the
future
joe now urges anyone with concerns to
get checked and feels fortunate his
cancer was treated in time
becky johnson sky news